[Music]
hello this is a comprehensive paper
review on a paper called avoiding
catastrophe active dendrites enable
multi-task learning in dynamic
environments this is a very cool paper
because it combines ideas that come from
biology which are active dendrites and
ideas that come from deep learning
namely the problems that we face in
multi-task learning and in continuous
learning catastrophic forgetting is one
of the main problems of these areas and
the method of active dendrites directly
inspired by biology can really help with
that so this video is a comprehensive
review on the method of active dendrites
in deep learning as the paper describes
it by the end of the video you'll have a
good understanding of what is in the
paper in the next video that i'll
publish tomorrow there will be an
interview with the authors which was
also super interesting and i definitely
invite you to check out both as always
if you have any comments please leave
them in the comments on youtube leave a
like if you do like the video and i'll
see you around bye-bye
hello there today we're going to look at
avoiding catastrophe active dendrites
enable multi-task learning in dynamic
environments this is by researchers of
nomenta cornell and stanford so this
paper proposes to bring some of what has
been lost in translation from real
biological neurons to deep learning
neurons to bring some of that back into
the deep learning neurons specifically
the concept of what they call active
dendrites and also a bit of sparsity
that is to be found in biological
neurons so they bring these back into
deep learning neural networks and it
turns out that that is pretty useful to
combat something known as catastrophic
forgetting thus the title of the paper
avoiding catastrophe so catastrophic
forgetting is a phenomenon where in
multi-task learning or continual
learning a network has to learn many
things at once and then these things
interfere with one another and it turns
out that our methods of training neural
networks using back propagation aren't
really good at that so either they don't
learn any of the tasks because they
conflict with each other or in continual
learning they do this catastrophic
forgetting where as soon as a new task
comes in they've completely forget about
the old task so many solutions obviously
have been proposed and this right here
isn't like is not entirely ultra novel
but it is interesting it ties together
biology and sort of practical applied
deep learning and it does have some
connections to for example modern
transformer architectures and so on so
i'd also be interested to hear what you
think how this stuff is all connected so
they start out uh saying that
a artificial neural networks they call
these a and ns so whatever you you in
this paper a ns means sort of the deep
learning neural networks we have to be a
bit careful when we talk about things
that involve biology because neural
networks is an ambiguous term there like
the neural networks is an ambiguous term
because it appears in both domains so
they they claim they fail dramatically
when learning multiple tasks a
phenomenon known as catastrophic
forgetting and i already said
catastrophic forgetting it essentially
means that you can't learn many things
at once so it says learning multiple
sequential tasks can lead to significant
interference between tasks they look at
two different they look at two different
tasks right here one is multi-task
reinforcement learning and the other one
is continual learning so in multi-task
reinforcement learning it's essentially
reinforcement learning with multiple
tasks so you're some sort of an agent
and you're in some sort of environment
and you have this basic loop of sending
an action and getting back some kind of
observation and reward however however
uh there are multi there are many tasks
in this environment so maybe you see it
and maybe you don't that's a part of the
definition of the problem i think in
this particular environment you also get
back kind of an indicator of which let's
call that t the task indicator so which
task you currently supposed to fulfill
so the same environment has many tasks
and then obviously your reward is going
to be dependent on which task is
currently active so you're going to give
the agent a mixture so every new episode
the agent tackles the task is different
and therefore if the agent just does the
same thing as in the last episode it
might get a completely different reward
because the task is different right so
that is multi-task reinforcement
learning and it turns out that and this
papers have established this before and
i think we haven't made a video on some
of them that if you look at the the
gradients they often conflict with one
another so learning one task would pull
a weight in some direction and learning
another task would pull it sort of in a
different direction and there are papers
that try to make these gradients as like
orthogonal as possible or project them
somehow into a task specific subspace
but as it stands conflicting gradients
can arise in these multi-task settings
and therefore the classic way of
training neural networks with back
propagation to update all the weights at
the same time just isn't very conducive
even worse in continual learning so here
we're not necessarily in reinforcement
learning anymore although we could be
um
so this is this is simply continual
learning where you present a neural
network so you have a neural network the
neural network is able to you know take
whatever picture
let's say it's a picture classification
and give you some sort of a class label
for that picture and now you have
different tasks so you have task one
task one
might be
uh classify
you know classify cats from dogs then
task two
might be classify
i don't know cows from beavers tasks and
so on so there is also a bit of a
specification gap some of these
continual learning benchmarks they will
always have the same classes but
different data sets some will have
different classes some will have new
classes and so on in this particular
case we're looking at permuted mnist
which is sort of the mnist data set so
you know there is whatever a picture
and there is some sort of handwritten
digit in here and the the permuted mnist
data set is simply that every task that
you consider so task one would have a
permutation applied to all the pixels in
in this uh picture but always the same
permutation and then task two would
apply sort of a different permutation
permutation one permutation two so it's
kind of a different task it's the same
classes you're still classifying digits
into zero to nine but the the
permutation is different therefore it's
like you have to to learn a new task if
you don't have some sort of built-in
symmetry prior in your neural network
obviously this
we're not going to use convnets right
here because confnets would make no
sense if your pixels are permuted we're
simply going to use feet forward
networks the goal isn't to get state of
the art the goal is to show the
difference between what if we use uh
regular neural networks and you can
imagine right here
if i train on task one right here um
task one has some kind of a permutation
in the pixels uh i'm able you know these
neural networks they're able to learn
that because if their feet for networks
they don't care about neighborhood
anyway so they they are able to you know
we train we train these weights right
here to to completion and then i
activate task two right right after task
one i stop giving the network data from
task one and i start giving it data from
task two so also different permutation i
also label my images give it to task two
now i'm gonna train these weights i
continue training these weights and
there is some effect when we talk about
large language model pre-training in
that
whatever you pre-train on that kind of
stays around so any fine-tuning in large
language models isn't going to
completely erase the pre-training so so
it actually matters what you pre-train
um although
this is not the same right here first of
all we're dealing with way smaller
networks and these way smaller networks
they're able to be kind of overwritten
mostly and also we're dealing with
classification tasks right here and not
some sort of language modeling
task so yeah these these weights they
will just be overwritten to the point
where task one is forgotten it's nowhere
so we've again if we draw up some sort
of a weight
um task one would pull it in this
direction that would be the gradient so
the weight would slowly uh update by
update going this direction and then all
of a sudden we activate task two which
will pull it in this direction so the
weight would then travel into this
direction and um essentially forget
about task one so it is nowhere near
where it should be for task one
as i said there are some methods of
solving this with orthogonal projections
and so on but
as a basic rule
our deep networks aren't very good at
that
so what what do we do about it this
paper's idea is that since our deep
networks use a model of the neuron that
looks very much like the thing on the
left so you have your your input weights
which are commonly known as the weight
matrix or the weights of the layer
this is just one row or column
i guess
well it depends on how you specify the
layer but these are just all the input
weights going into one neuron they're
summed up so this is the matrix
multiplication and then there is some
sort of a non-linearity right here which
could be a sigmoid which could be a tan
h which could be a relu and that's
essentially still the model that we have
this is
like an over like it's it's decades old
this this model and it's served us
pretty well but it has forgotten some
very important aspect of biology here on
the right you see uh a pyramidal neuron
a
pyramidal a pyramidal i'm just gonna
call it pyramidal because of pyramid um
so
this is obviously uh way different so
well first of all it's not a schematic
it's kind of like an actual drawing you
see the axon right here and the axon
splits up into different parts which is
you know is like our regular neurons
they connect to all the neurons in the
next layer although one difference is
you can already see that there are way
less connections
from here than you would have in a fully
connected layer so there is a degree of
sparsity in biological neural networks
that is not represented in the deep
neural networks that we build
and then the inputs right here
we just consider all the inputs to be
the same however there is a difference
between what they call proximal inputs
and distal inputs so proximal inputs
would be inputs that are very close to
the cell's body
and those behave very much like the
linear linear influence that we see in
our model however there are also these
distal by the way these things are
called dendrites um they're not there's
a difference between the axon which is
this thing here and the dendrites which
is this thing here every neuron has one
axon but can have many many dendrites
and dendrites are sort of like they're
just kind of elongations of the cell
body so any any other axon could dock
either directly on the cell body or
close to it or could dock on any of the
dendrites so you can make connections
from axon to body or from axon to
dendrites and dendrites are kind of like
harbors like like ports or or docks for
for incoming traffic yeah that's
how i can explain it however these
distal dendrites they they're they're
not acting like as much as like linear
things what they are doing is and this
paper describes that um is they act like
their own little subunit that computes
its own function so it's almost like a
mini neuron inside a neuron and that
mini neuron can then influence or
modulate uh the cell body so whenever
that mini neuron is for example very
high is very activated
it
it will
raise or lower the activation threshold
for the main cell body so it can sort of
influence
the main cell body in a multiplicative
way and that's exactly what we're going
to see in this architecture
so
yeah i've i've sort of skipped a lot of
the text right here um
yeah if you if you're a patreon you get
these notes i hope i hope they help
i've never considered my scribbles to be
super duper helpful but i've started
pre-annotating and i hope it helps
someone um but yeah these are mostly for
me to see what i have to what i have to
look at so what does that have to do
with continual learning well
they describe right here they
hypothesize that biological properties
of
pyramidal neurons in the neocortex can
enable targeted context-specific
representations that avoid interference
so pyramidal neurons which comprise most
cells in the neocortex are significantly
more sophisticated demonstrate a wide
range of complex non-linear dendrite
specific integrative properties
and
they are hypothesizing that this
modulation property that we've just
discussed this modulation property could
battle this catastrophic forgetting
specifically what they say is that well
we have many of these dendritic distal
sub modules and these could learn and
there is some biological evidence for
that to recognize different contexts in
which you are in
and depending on which of these is
active that means which context is
recognized it can modulate the body of
the cell so the cell could react
differently depending on the context and
that is one of the ingredients exactly
that we need to avoid this catastrophic
forgetting or do multiple tasks at the
same time is to say hey i'm only going
to activate my cell body if
i'm in the correct context meaning for
example a particular task is active
so the cell body can learn its weights
to do to specialize on a given task and
rely on these subunits to recognize when
it needs to fire and obviously if
there's some structure to the tasks we
can also think of these being sub tasks
so subtasks are sort of being activated
that can then generalize and be
integrated into multiple tasks and so on
so
there's a bit of related work
the active dendrites that is pretty much
pretty much what i just described uh you
can see each distal dendritic segment
acts as a separate active subunit
performing its own local computation
when input to an active dendritic
segment reaches a threshold the segment
initiates a dendritic spike so this is
not a neural like axon spike it's a
dendritic spike that travels to the cell
body okay i've apparently memorized this
passage and can depolarize the neuron
for an extended period of time sometimes
as long as half a second they don't
model time dependency right here by the
way that's something they don't
integrate right here during this time
yet the cell is significantly closer to
its firing threshold and any new input
is more likely to make the cell fire
this suggests that active dendrites have
a modulatory long lasting impact on the
cells response with very different role
than proximal or feed-forward inputs so
they say they typically receive
contextual input that is a different
input than received in proximal segments
proximal or the near ones these contact
signals can arrive from other neurons in
the same layer neurons in other layers
or from the top down feedback another
thing they don't model right here
is is any sort of top-down feedback or
same layer or anything like this just
i'm just taking this away what they do
model is these dendritic subunits
the second thing they're very interested
in is sparsity so sparse representations
are ubiquitous in biological neural
networks not so much in deep neural
networks they claim that studies show
that relatively few neurons spike in
response to a sensory stimulus across
multiple sensory modalities sparsity is
also present in the connectivity
and
they claim that one advantage of
sparsity and representations
is that vectors for two separate
entities have low overlap so they're now
talking about deep networks because
biological networks don't have vectors
so they're talking about how if you
impose sparsity in a deep neural network
and you are in high dimensions then your
representations likely will not collide
because a lot of the entries are zero
low representation overlap among
unrelated inputs may be particularly
useful when an artificial neural network
is learning multiple unrelated tasks and
that's why they are interested in the
sparse representations because if
different things don't
aren't likely to overlap they're not
likely to interfere with each other and
therefore they might be useful to combat
catastrophic forgetting so two things
we're going to implement these active
dendrites into our models and also we're
going to implement a degree of sparsity
and we're going to observe how these two
things work together to combat the
catastrophic forgetting phenomenon
that is essentially what this paper
suggests so let's look
at uh exactly how they do is do this i
think it's it's best to jump to the
the model right here so this is one of
the models or one of the architectures
they use this is the actual arc they use
two-layer neural networks so yeah this
is these are these are not these are not
huge networks that they use right here
it is for reinforcement learning so it
is kind of a soft actor critic they use
this benchmark right here where a
robotic arm needs to perform multiple
tasks in the same world and in this
particular task the agent always gets
the information which task is active so
which task is active goes into this
context vector on the left this is a one
hot vector that is fed as a context
signal what's special about this network
is that first of all you can see that
there is a linear layer and that is not
some classic linear layer that is a
special linear layer namely the active
dendrite linear layer so the active
dendrite linear layer has
a feed forward signal and that feed
forward signal is treated just as a
classic
deep neural network feed forward signal
so that would be the feed forward signal
would essentially be whatever the input
here is in this case probably the
robot's state or something and its
position and it's uh maybe the the
position of the
whatever object it needs to grab if
that's not always at the same place and
so on so that's the state input and if
it if you're only one task the network
could just learn from this input however
this is multiple tasks so it gets the
context vector the alternative the
baseline what the baseline would do is
it would append the context vector right
here and just sort of extend this feed
forward layer and it would say well the
network essentially has access to this
information um right here in its input
so it should technically be able to
handle that however they're going to
show that you know they're going to
implement this in a baseline going to
show that that's not as helpful as what
they're doing so we have a feed forward
signal and um that computes some output
you can see that's independent of this
context vector so the feed forward layer
the weights of the feed forward layer
which sit approximately here they're
going to be you know multiplied by the
weight matrix summed up and then there's
some output signal right here just in a
classic feed forward layer the context
vector comes in here
and what it's what it's going to do
remember this is a one hot vector uh for
now there they make it more complicated
later it is going to be matched with
each of what these things are these
things are called dendritic segments so
it is going to be matched with each of
them and the matching is simply done via
an inner product that's what this little
sum symbol does right here so there's an
inner product between the context vector
and the dendritic segment and then
they're going to select
whatever dendritic segment matched the
highest and that is going into here and
then here is a modulation function so
the
signal that is the highest the highest
inner product with whatever dendritic
segment is going out here and modulates
that signal and that's going to be the
output
now let's look at how these dendritic
segments work because that's really sort
of the the meat right here
here you can see the forward signal the
forward signal is your classic signal
right here
um there's a weight matrix or vector in
this case there's the input there's a
values okay
the dendritic segments
are
they're just vectors these are trained
okay every single one of these dendritic
segments is a set of weights
that is trained and it's different as
far as i can understand each neuron has
its own dendritic segments and for each
dendritic segments it has its own
weights so there's no weight sharing
going on among the dendritic segments
which would i think break the whole the
whole thing although i guess one could
come up with some sort of smart like
meta weight sharing right here but the
idea is that um
as you can see from the formula we're
simply going to take the context vector
calculate the inner product with all of
these dendritic segments take the max
indirect segment that's going to be some
kind of a number right this is an inner
product so this is the strength of
whichever dendritic segment matched the
most and then we're going to take a
non-linearity in this case a sigmoid
function and we're going to multiply the
at the feed forward signal that we have
with this
sigmoid function of the
of this inner product so this can
you know the sigmoid is between zero and
one i i think yeah i think they retain
the sign so they take the max absolute
value in the end but let's leave that
out for now so whichever segment matches
the most that's some number that goes
through a sigmoid so let's think about
this when is this thing one it's one
whenever
one of these dendritic segments
activated right
so we take since we take the max one of
them needs to activate and then this
thing is one so the dendritic segments
they are sort of like
like uh receptors for
contexts that where this neuron could be
relevant so they are sort of like you
know feature detectors and if they they
expose some kind of uh some kind of
vector they they are obviously vectors
so in the space there's like here like
you know i have maybe i have three of
these dendritic segments and i say well
i'm interested
if if my representation if my context
representation is any of those three in
that direction then i'm interested so if
the context comes in like this
they they're just like no one is
interested therefore the sigmoided
maximum is going to be zero and it's
going to block the signal right here
however if the context comes in is very
close to what one of these segments is
then it's like oh wow this actually
might be relevant for this neuron
therefore the sigmoid
so the inner product is high the sigmoid
of the inner product is high and the
signal is going to be propagated through
interestingly in the experiments they
always expose like as many dendritic
segments per neuron as they have tasks
which i thought to criticize that
because i was like well that's kind of
cheating but now i don't even know if
that if that is necessarily like
wouldn't one dendritic segment suffice
like if it could perfectly recognize if
every neuron was only relevant for one
task and if that could be perfectly
recognized by the context vector i guess
that would that would work but this is
more powerful right you can present a
number of situations where you would be
interested in ah i guess okay if you
have as many dendritic segments as you
have tasks then every neuron could be
relevant for every task so a neuron
could be relevant for all tasks or for
just two of the tasks and so on
so yeah i still maintain it's a bit of
it's a bit of cheating to make as many
dendritic segments as you have
um as you have
tasks because that's implicitly telling
the network how many tasks you have but
you do get you do get the task as as the
context
so you already know anyway right
in any case that's that's what this
network does it exposes these things
it's able to take this context signal
and uh modulate that signal the second
thing it does is this
k
winner takes all and this is this is
very much like
maybe the sort of sparse mixture of
experts that you might know from from
transformers or the concept so what it
does is it simply calculates a
a maximum maximum activation over the
entire layer and it only lets through
the
highest the highest
k many things so it's k winner takes all
k could be
three or five or something like this but
in any case it is not as many as you
have neurons and all the other neurons
they're just set to zero therefore they
also don't receive any gradient so here
you can see how these two things play
together
first of all we're going to modulate so
we're going to block a lot of the
signals right here blocking means we're
just going to multiply them by a very
small number if they're not relevant and
then it's not just that they're very
small
actually we're just going to pick like
the top five so all the numbers that are
small we're just going to eliminate
completely i don't know if this you know
this method of achieving sparsity is
necessarily the best one to pick the k
best or if it'd be better to just
threshold somewhere um because k
then is some sort of other hyper
parameter that you might you know set
via cheating or that you might have to
to try out and
some some sort of a threshold might be
more robust especially since the the
sigmoid
um is fairly fairly steep function yeah
that's
that's the architecture essentially so i
hope you can see how this sort of
connects to to other things um
especially i'm interested in this
modulation property and i'm also
interested in in the sparsity approach
obviously if you have sparse
representations there's not going to be
any gradient flowing back through the
neurons that weren't activated and
therefore there's not going to be any
gradient into these neurons that means
these weights here aren't trained for
that particular neuron it means these
dendritic segments which are again these
are parameters trainable parameters so
these blue arrows
are back propagate trainable they will
only update if the neuron has actually
been selected in in its forward pass so
they're
random at the beginning and then with
time they will fine-tune for specific
context so they will sort of move and
yeah there is a bit of a danger that
some of these are just become ghost
parameters but i guess as stuff moves
around um and as initializations are
diverse and random enough
almost everything will will become sort
of selected at some point um if your
inputs are diverse enough
yeah so
that's that i've skipped a lot of these
uh a lot of the the text right here um
you can see the k the k wt the k winner
takes all representation we're simply
gonna let the signal through
if it's in the top k activations and
it's zero otherwise
yeah
exactly so here they say only the
neurons that were selected by the wta
function will have non-zero activations
and thus non-zero gradients only the
weights corresponding to those neurons
will be updated and that's how the two
things work together to battle
catastrophic forgetting in that
if the
context
if the dendritic segments successfully
learn to recognize different tasks that
means that only the neurons that are
involved in a particular tasks will will
be updated by that task and therefore
the network will not nest will not
forget the other tasks or not forget
them as easily because the sparsity also
the sparsity kind of forces not all
parameters to be updated and the
dendritic segments forces these sparse
updates to be in a very structured uh
very consistent fashion
and yeah they also say that only the
dendritic segment j that was chosen by
the max operator is updated all other
segments remain untouched so even if a
neuron is part of this k top k
activations only one dendritic segment
is updated namely the one that matched
the most with the context and this again
ensures that maybe if a neuron is
relevant to different tasks
the other dendritic segments they can
they can keep their place even if we
train in a new task where this neuron is
also
relevant if it was relevant to an old
task that might be stored in a different
dendritic segment than the one that is
activated right now and that dendritic
segment due to the max operator will not
receive a gradient and will just remain
as it is
of course this doesn't scale you know
forever and to all degrees of noise and
there is a
there is a way in which tasks can be too
related so i would guess that in a model
like this if tasks are very related um
they will activate the same dendritic
segments and therefore override each
other but then also if tasks are very
related you would expect that there's
some form of generalization or crossover
among them but the difficulty has never
been that much with generalization it
has always been with the fact that if
you think of for example large language
models i also think of large language
models as continual training they they
often they don't even run an a single
epoch over some of the data and they
still learn from it so they see a data
point once right and and then you know
that's that's that and they still are
able to incorporate that somehow so how
are they not subject to catastrophic
forgetting they also in a way implement
different tasks because i can query gpt3
with so much stuff like it can do so
much different diverse things it is all
it is like a bit of you know sure it's
always the same loss and the gradients
don't necessarily conflict of that loss
but it's kind of a multi-task learning
and one key difference is that gpt3 is
presented with sort of an iid shuffled
sample of the training data however here
the all the data of task 1 comes first
and then all the data of tasks 2 comes
later so even if there's some
generalization aspect i would expect if
tasks are close together task two will
overwrite task one um because the same
dendritic segments might activate and
just from the model here they don't have
a way to i feel they don't have a way to
battle that maybe they are there of a
different opinion but maybe some sort of
uh how should i say this some sort of a
contrastive method like a contrastive
addition to these dendritic segments
like pushing them apart from each other
for for different tasks you know if they
have the task information or just plain
pushing them apart from each other maybe
hallucinating pseudo tasks for that may
be a way to to automatically adjust to
how close together or far apart uh the
different tasks are yeah that that's
just my
what i would guess might help but maybe
i'm completely wrong tell me what you
think they say we hypothesize that a
functional specialization will emerge
where different dendritic segments will
each learn to identify specific context
vectors
so that's the model now they go into the
experiments as we already said they do
two things multitask reinforcement
learning this is this robot thing so
it's all at the same time in this
particular case it's not one after
another it's all at the same time i
think each batch is always from the same
task but like the next batch will be of
a different tasks i think yeah but it's
different tasks right so the same
actions don't lead to the same reward
and that is means conflicting gradients
they use a very basic rl algorithm right
here which is not necessarily important
for our discussion just to say that the
networks are quite small right they have
two hidden layers each with 2
800 neurons which okay that's that's
sizable so they're they're quite they're
quite fat hidden layers but it's just
two of them and then each one is
followed by a
k winner takes all activation function
and then there's the final output layer
they say ah the first layer has standard
neurons whereas the second layer hidden
the second hidden layer contains active
dendrite neurons which are modulated by
the context vector in this case the
context vector just encodes the task id
as a one hot vector
and yeah
each active dendrite neuron in our
network has exactly 10 dendritic
segments the same as the number of tasks
to learn they do ablations where they
increase uh that number of of dendritic
segments but
yeah i i do think they're giving their
model the absolute best chance to learn
right here
by setting some some of these parameters
with essentially okay it's not hidden
information in this particular case but
it is in the next case where we're not
getting the task id as you will see so
this is how the model looks there's the
state vector there's feed forward we
have some sparsity enforced by these
notice that it's really interesting that
sparsity um is even enforced here
without any without any modulation
uh and they do also some ablations on
that but i'd be interested why they
didn't choose to also have dendritic
segments in the first layer uh it seems
quite odd honestly to to set up an
experiment like this yeah and the other
thing is they say although we control
the hidden sizes to yield approximately
the same number
of total non-zero parameters we know
that mlp baseline contains nearly 500k
more non-zero parameters than our active
dendrite networks they speak a lot of
these non-zero parameters and they count
the network sizes in non-zero parameters
so i would be
interested what are
what's the difference between parameters
and non-zero parameters and and what it
was is a non-zero i don't i've not seen
this exactly explained in the paper is
is that
like at the end of training if a
parameter is zero you don't count it or
is it somehow different
i i don't know but
safe to say they do try to make the
networks as
you know with the same number of tr of
parameters which means that if they have
these dendritic segments which are quite
a number of parameters
they have to
i mean not that many compared but they
have to turn down
the um
the other parameters so here you can see
the results at the beginning the active
dendrites network in blue is sort of
underperforming but then it overtakes
the the baseline the mlp baseline
and um yeah the errors here the
variances are quite large as you can see
um they do
run another analysis where they just
select the top five for each
and you can see that it separates a bit
more cleanly although i'm not sure if
that is like a
is that is that a thing like can you say
i'm just going to select like the top
five of each to reduce the variance um
i'm not sure if the
the the the max distribution is
uh the same as
the mean distribution
like could i do that in practice
maybe not if i just have one run
uh which is essentially what i'd want to
do in practice i i couldn't necessarily
do that i don't know
in any case they beat the mlp baseline
in both cases you can see that sometimes
there are pretty significant differences
um
especially in what they claim are the
harder tasks like the pick place tasks
and these are are also the tasks that
have very little overlap with the other
tasks so you would expect greater
interference and that's where they have
a lot of uh gains in
gains against the
the baselines
in continual learning they use this
permuted mnist as we've discussed and um
so yeah here's here is sort of the the
comparison um yeah you can see also you
can see here the variants are are huge
for some of these tasks
sorry yeah in the
permuted mnist data set they okay they
don't have a a graph i believe
but in the permuted mnist data set they
also
are
beating or are
advancing against the baseline
significantly so we have
somewhere
there are the results
so you can see right here
there isn't a baseline in this
particular diagram but you can see that
the the drop-off
is
not very steep and
usually if you do this with regular mlps
they just fail like they they fail which
means that so this test accuracy
is on all the tasks you've seen so far
so you get presented with whatever 20
tasks in sequence and you evaluate on
all of them and regular mlps they just
suck at this like they forget the
previous tasks and um
yeah that's that's that so the fact that
these networks are able to sort of hold
up across and here you can see up to
like 100 tasks is already pretty
remarkable they have two different
variants one where the prototype is
given while training which essentially
means they have information about which
task they're in and one is where the
prototype is inferred and they describe
these up here
so what they do they now switch over
from not providing the task id as a
context signal because that's kind of
cheating and they provide now these this
proto
type so what is a prototype a prototype
is essentially a data point or it can be
a latent vector but here i think it's
just a data point that is kind of the
mean data point
so this will be the prototype of task a
the mean data point of all the data
points in a particular task so they
provide that as the context as the
context signal
now what they can do now is
here you can see how that works it's
just a mean well i told you
what they can do is
if they don't have a task annotation if
they don't know what task goes with a
particular data point they can simply
collect data points during training they
can say well here's a data point here's
one here's one and here's one right and
it helps that they have the guarantee
that each batch has the same task um and
then they say well okay we're gonna make
a prototype right here and that's going
to be our
context vector
and then the next batch comes in and
it's kind of like over here and they say
well this is not very close so we're
going to make a new prototype right here
and then the next batch comes in and
it's like here and i say ah that's
probably of the same thing again so
we're going to use that prototype
to provide to the system so it's kind of
this heuristic thing averaging the data
points which i find to be quite weak
like averaging the pure data points is
like um it might work in permuted mnist
but there's definitely room for
improvement right there because that is
not going to be informative at all in
in many or most tasks and obviously
there's also like a hyper parameter to
set like you know what's what's that the
appropriate distance measure right here
um
and also this is just going into this as
the context signal and the context
signal is essentially just worked out by
inner product as we saw up sorry up here
so
the
signal is just it's just an inner
product with some of these u vectors uh
if this gets any more complicated there
is going to need to be a lot of
machinery in front of the context vector
like
i would expect
we need to pass it at least through some
hidden layers to compute something of of
value
but for permuted mnist it's going to be
enough right
so they recognize which tasks they're in
now i am interested
why exactly they switched from providing
the task id like at least in first in
the first instance and why they switched
over to providing these prototypes right
here
as the context signal right just
experimentally they have this one
experiment in this one setting where
they they just provide the task id and
then they have
the
other setting where they do something
diff i would i would get it if they did
both things in the same setting um but
having two different settings and just
doing two different things is a bit
suspicious i guess and also here you can
see they provided actually to both
layers and not just to one layer i would
like to know the story behind this they
also compare to a baseline which is
called s i
so s i as they describe here it is a
thing that operates solely at the level
of synapses it maintains an additional
parameter per weight that controls the
speed of weights adapting to specific
tasks the two approaches are
complementary that's why they can be
combined
you can see on the right so on the left
hand side you can see what happens if
you infer these prototypes during
training and you can see it's just a
little bit worse which i think is like a
hundred percent
so i don't know how much better or worse
they would be if they actually gave the
task id
um but i think this distance right here
that is only going to be
uh possible on permuted mnist um
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm wrong
so here you can see interestingly right
here is the active dendrites it it uh
this is kind of the the curve from the
left and then this s i method just by
itself actually beats the active
dendrites
however you can combine both as you can
see and both together are stronger and
give you an even better better boost
so that is
i mean it's it's uh it's
it's good if you can combine all the
tricks that you had so far
i would have like to have here like a
like okay the mlps they just suck um
because right now it's not exactly clear
how much they suck um although i i'm i'm
sure that there's some appendix table
and i haven't looked i haven't found it
the paper is quite long
so
here they
compare to a different method which is
called
xdg
which is
context dependent gating sorry so they
say this is the implementation closest
to to theirs this is another idea
however that one uses hard-coded
distinct sub-network for each task so
this is pre-allocated it pre-allocates
says
sub network you're for task one you're
for task two you're for task three they
engineer this in a way where they expect
some overlap between the tasks um and
some separate neurons and then they only
train the sub-network so they need the
task id to be provided the
implementation invokes task specific
subset of the hidden layer other neurons
are forced to have an activation value
of zero
this requires a task id that determines
exactly which neurons to turn on or off
it turns out so the way they emphasize
all of this is that
it turns out that
they do beat the baseline as you can see
right here
when you just do them by themselves but
as soon as you combine them with this si
technique the
the
the xdg outperforms the active dendrites
so
obviously they they need to highlight
the differences right here which is a
good tactic right and it's valid they
they do do more so here they say task
information is inferred it's not
provided via this prototyping where this
provides a system with a task id during
training and testing right and it's
important to see that even if they do
the prototyping with the information of
the task id
they claim that during inference time
there is no task id provided and they
simply you know they see whatever if a
data point is whatever prototype the
data point is closest to that's the
prototype they take
um
the second thing
sub networks
automatically emerge via the use of
dendritic segments in their model
whereas the baseline it pre-allocates
different sub-networks for each tasks
and that's that's legitimate however i
don't i can't shake the feeling that
they've like evaluated it and then this
thing was better and they were like ah
rats no what can we what can we do okay
we can't beat it how can we make it how
can we make it different enough and
maybe
that's when they decided okay let's try
to like not provide the task id but
let's try to come up with like a dynamic
way of figuring out the task or
something like this maybe that's the
story behind why this prototyping exists
or maybe that that has like that just
turned out
uh like it is i don't know but
you know it's it's interesting it's
interesting to see um sort of
there might there might be a research
process behind this and
which is cool because the research
process sort of leads to more innovation
which is neat there is an important
question one that which i also had
during reading of this paper and
no that's not it this
we're gonna get to that first they check
their hypotheses so they say the
hypotheses of our work are twofold first
active dendrite networks modulate an
individual neurons activations for each
task second the winner takes all
activations use this modulation to
activate sub-networks that correspond to
each task
they provide some evidence for this so
here on the left and the right you see
the two tasks they tackle
and they give you an impression of
which hidden units
are active for which particular task
and
they you can see that
it's fairly sparse so if you look at any
given
column or at any given row then not many
light up in dark green which means that
not many things are activated per tasks
and a given unit is kind of specialized
to particular tasks or a particular set
of tasks now
without a comparison to
a sort of regular neural network or
without a comparison to to
one of the two
features of the network ablated it's
kind of hard to to see whether this is a
lot or not a lot especially on the on
the right you can also see like is this
sparse or is this not sparse i don't
know i'm gonna guess it is um
yeah so
i i don't i don't know i'm gonna believe
them that this is especially sparse um
and i think they also measured it at
some point actually the sparsity but
just the the graphic alone isn't this
isn't necessarily enough for me they
look at single neurons so
in the single neuron they wonder which
dendritic segment
is responding to which task right
there's neuron a and neuron b
um and you can see at initialization a
lot of the segments are responding to a
lot of the tasks however after learning
it becomes much more
quiet and only very few segments are
responding to to any or each of the
tasks however also here first of all
it's not
it's not super clear what we are to
compare this with because this could
just be
this could just be a phenomenon of kind
of like the scale of stuff being wrong
um like at initialization just the
scaling of things being kind of out of
out of whack because you can see right
here there are entire regions that are
just kind of dimming down right um so
yeah obviously a given a given neuron
isn't going to respond to all the tasks
right with all the segments it's not
going to be involved in all of the tasks
that would actually you know this this
is a valid prediction of their
hypotheses um and you can also see that
especially neuron b here if you look at
segment 8 multiple dendritic segments
are reacting
to signal 8 which might be an indication
that there is some you know they have
learned to recognize different features
that all indicate that 4
no segment 8 responds to multiple tasks
ah okay that's that's different
okay negate my argument forget what i
said um i i thought i thought it was a
smart recognition but you know it's it
is it is definitely evidence for the
fact that there's specialization going
on but uh without a comparison to
anything it's hard to tell if that is
that or just some sort of a scaling
scaling issue that just after training
things are scaled differently but just
you know from
from all the other evidence they make a
convincing case that there is this
sparsity and specialization going on so
here
is the last thing i want to discuss and
this is a question that i had when
reading this paper which is aren't like
isn't this isn't there an equivalence
from two larger networks like aren't you
just sort of uh
sort of
you know designing this this network in
this special way and can't i achieve the
same thing with sort of a
a regular neural network if i just make
it a bit larger
they say multiple studies have suggested
that that that dendritic computations
performed by
pyramidal neurons can be approximated by
artificial neural networks that have one
or more hidden layers
from a computational and deep learning
perspective this is equivalent to
claiming that a and ns with dendrites
can be substituted by larger a ns
without dendrites
proposedly and i have tried so they are
going to make the case right here that
that is not the case
that
they are outperforming for example
three-layer mlps which are about the
same size and mlps that are much larger
so much deeper so they're going to
outperform them at you can see right
here number of tasks 100 oh this is
this is probably the graph i was looking
for before no yeah so here you can see
how much how much the uh the mlps suck
so yeah they they show that even if you
scale them up in fact the 10-layer mlp
is even worse which is interesting
um which might be might be interesting
in itself like
why is it why is it worse and is there
like a crossover point here but in any
case these mlps they get the context
vector
as an input right so technically
technically they have all the
information to do the same thing however
the paper argues that it's the training
procedure
back propagation updating all the
weights for the given data that is
presented to us
this is particular to an iid setting of
data which we don't have right here so
no matter how big you make your neural
network supposedly if they are correct
um this it would always result in the
same problems due to the way that you
train them on the left you see an
ablation
of the two ingredients so the active
dendrites only the sparse
representations only and the combination
on second
so they do certainly give empirical
evidence and by the way here is also an
ablation
on having more dendritic segments on the
top they're trying to learn 10 tasks on
the bottom they're trying to learn
100 no 50 tasks
and it's interesting to see that the
gains here
are kind of negligible although maybe
that's just a property that they're
very close to 100 already and here you
can kind of see gains
until 50 and then well okay i might be
imagining things that there's stronger
gains here than here after you pass sort
of the number of tasks barrier
yeah but safe to say that you know more
more dendritic segments might also be
useful and uh maybe my skepticism
of them setting parameters exactly
exactly as many as sort of exactly to
the number of tasks they have is not
super warranted also interesting is the
uh
the
fixed number of dendritic segments and
varying activation density level so here
is this k so how many things they let
through each layer you can see it
increases to the right this would be a
hundred percent which would regress to a
classic mlp see if you activate a
hundred percent it's it's really bad and
there are two things right here again
they're trying to learn 10 tasks or 50
tasks interestingly interestingly if at
the beginning obviously that nothing
through it kind of sucks then you let
some things through it's already really
good and then it gets better so there's
some kind of an optimum
around 10
ish or so interestingly that's the case
for both the things even though one is
trying to learn significantly more tasks
which is interesting right then there is
a drop-off for both things which you
would expect but then there is kind of
like a flat flattening
followed by another drop-off and it's
also interesting to um
to think about why that's the case so
here it might be
that this is the situation where
uh
very few things are overlapping and
therefore the network is able to
use specialized sub networks for all the
things that it needs to do
and in this entire region up until here
it might be the case you see it kind of
drops off at the end after like 80
percent it might be the case that most
of the things are shared however the
network can kind of encode stuff in the
non-shared part and that can itself
within the network kind of modulate
whatever the shared stuff is doing it's
kind of like a shared feature extractor
followed by some modulation of the
non-shared parts i would yeah it's
interesting to think and then that
crashes together once there is no more
non-shared parts and there's no way of
doing anything different in the
different task settings
i was thinking myself you know
getting back sorry getting back to
can i just achieve the same thing with a
larger network i was thinking myself of
how to do that so they claim no you
cannot and
i guess it's true let's think of okay
this let's leave the sparsity away let's
just think of this dendritic activation
right i have my x
that's multiplied by by w
and let's also leave the biases away so
i have my x vector down here i have some
w which is a weight matrix so
everything's connected to everything
till here now can i also and i have my
context vector can i somehow build a
feed-forward network that would also you
know have the appropriate weight
connections that i could
build myself the function w x
times stigmoid
u
c
let's also leave away the max right
right here i guess okay we can't
that's an integral part
um
and yeah it's not clear to me how that
would work necessarily with uh
with
a single layer and it's also not
entirely clear to me how that would work
with multiple layers like
you would have to build some very con
like various contraptions of of
additions uh maybe you know once you get
a relu out
on all of that it might be more possible
but it's not easy to get this
multiplicative interactions between
signals working in a feed-forward
network um
however however in transformers that
might be different right so you know
this here
this you know we can do this in
transformers i guess in feed forward
networks too and then the max we have we
have soft maxes in transformers right so
what we could do is we could have these
things here as
let's call them queries right and these
things here are the keys
and
we apply the softmax in a transformer
and the values might just be a constant
vector of ones so the values might just
be constant vector of ones which would
mean that if we multiply the softmax by
this thing we would simply select sort
of the maximum out of that and that's
going to be one and everything else
might be zero
maybe am i
maybe i'm i have this wrong but
maybe not
yeah i guess that that would work right
so and then in the next layer so that
could be our output signal for layer one
and that could be our output signal for
layer one in a different attention head
and then the multiplicative interaction
again we can get by via attention
because attention constructs the
attention constructs the weights
uh dynamically by multiplication so we
could take
this as as keys and maybe also queries
and then simply this could be the values
right here and then we multiply them
together
and that's going to be a multiplicative
interaction between that signal over
here and the signal over here
so i guess transformers could model
something like this
it's not easy it's not going to be in
one layer it's not going to be
non-shared potentially right as it is
here so here nothing is shared of the
parameters
but i would i would argue
that
the more powerful method of the
transformer doing these dynamic weights
um
you know there might actually be some
connection here and as we said for the
sparsity we have sort of the sparse
mixture of experts which is kind of sort
of a little bit similar so
flicking through the rest of the paper i
don't i don't think i have anything
annotated right here there are hyper
parameters uh there are uh tables and
more results and methods but that's
essentially it what i had to say about
this paper i like this paper because it
sort of connects um connects biological
concepts it tries to reintroduce them it
augments
the
fundamental architecture that we have so
this is not very task specific right and
i think this can be augmented by quite a
bit with these sort of
side puts and and context signals and
maybe we need to we can think about
modulating inputs there's also an
interesting connection by the way to
like lstms which essentially do
exactly this right they an lstm has like
a c signal and an h signal i don't
exactly remember what they stand for but
let's just call c context and h the
hidden state and then there is the x the
input of that particular sequence and
then there's like uh there's like
various ways of multiplying them and
adding them and concatenating them and
multiplying those here right and then
modulating them via some sort of gating
and forget gates and so on so it is very
reminiscent of an just an lstm just not
recurrent but sort of this this gating
mechanism except the lstm obviously
constructs the context signal and the
hidden signal from from the same uh from
the same state so somewhere here
there are then outputs again like the
context and the hidden state for the
next vector but it's interesting
connections to all the things we have so
far and you know maybe maybe we could
bring them together
in sort of more simple more unified form
and i like that they applied it
specifically to
a particular task and they can show look
this helps for this particular thing all
right that was it from me i know this
was a bit longer but is a long paper as
a bit out of the box and i hope you
learned something i did certainly
let me know what you think and bye bye
you